retour en france avec la santé est un
sujet qui émerge depuis quelques années
le stress des cadres au travail
il serait devenu la deuxième source de
maladies professionnelles
il ne s'agit pas spécialement de
harcèlement la charge de travail est
souvent en cause le devoir de
performance aussi c'est le dossier de
cette édition il est signé anne guéri
eric de l'agneau jean-marie thaci et
patron d'une agence de communication
donc ici c'est la partie de plus des
tentes de lanvaux de l'entreprise et la
partie détente c'est l'atout charme de
l'entreprise aujourd'hui dans ces
milieux de la com et du web un coin cosy
histoire de se sentir au travail comme à
la maison
ambiance copain copain à les tâches
c'est l'open space pas de cloison entre
les bureaux il faut que l'information
circule donc le pôle projets qui en
contact directement avec la clientèle
lyannaj des cadres fils résolument
décontracté le battre on l'appelle gm
chacun le tutoie et il tutoie tout le
monde quand une réponse appropriée
jusque là mais attention trompe l'oeil
en réalité j aime est un redoutable
manager c'est action rectification
accélérations ont fait quelque chose
même si ce n'est pas parfait
rectification voilà on regarde ce qui
est pas parfait on corrige on améliore
accélération est donc une fois qu'on a
amélioré on enclenche la seconde vitesse
au coup de mou saint pas dit donc que sa
17e place pour l'économie
le monde de la performance des cadres
ultra flexible ultra réactif et au final
ils traquent carbonisés c'est ce qu'ont
vécu pendant dix ans les deux auteurs de
l'open space m'a tuer
chronique douce amère sur les cadres
trentenaires
c'est craquer les gens c'est qu'ils
travaillent sont pression dans l'urgence
et comme il faut qu'ils aient toujours
l'air enthousiaste
s'ils ont un jour où ça va moins ils
peuvent pas le montrer donc et ça ils
ont de la souffrance intériorisé donc
ils vont rentrer chez eux en disant rien
sur leur lieu de travail et prendre des
antidépresseurs pour tenir tenir ils
étaient formatés pour bardé de diplômes
très bien payé ils ont joué le jeu en a
plein qui a envie de changer
complètement de mode de vie avant de
tomber de haut finalement tu es content
de faire ce que tu fais de passer les
nuits au bureau de dire que t'as pas le
temps parce que tu as vraiment renault
d'être là à répondre nuitées jours à
tous et un jour au bout de quatre ans
elle s'est effondrée à 28 ans seulement
le corps a dit stop malaise après une
réunion avec new york fin c'était une de
ces encore de saigner ridicule
jean-pierre réveillère urgence trois
semaines de coeur de sommeil
aujourd'hui c'est la moitié des cadres
53% qui jugent leur travail très
stressant et le stress ça peut aller
jusqu'au suicide
c'est précisément ce qui est arrivé dans
une agence de la bnp en janvier dernier
un conseiller financier s'est tué parce
qu'il ne parvenait plus à atteindre ses
objectifs de ventilation pour ces deux
syndicalistes les objectifs c'est ce qui
fait souffrir les cadres tous ceux qui
sont au dessus son ton jaune imposée en
début d'année à chaque commercial
ils sont quantifiés semaine après
semaine en jaune les commerciaux qui
vendent bien en rose les moins beaux et
on l'en des champions donc l'élan vert
fluo on doit vendre sur un rendez vous
de trois produits minimum si on fait
moins il ya des moyennes qui sont
établis comme bien quelques sous les
clients qu'on a en face de soi
à certaines périodes on est on est
obligé dû proposer tel type de produit
ou ou tel type de service alors que
c'est pas du tout ce qui vient chercher
même quand on est bon on est de toute
façon mauvais le sauveur on invente
toujours des performances
supplémentaires des points d'efforts
supplémentaires et pour évaluer les
performances la banque classe les
salariés du premier au dernier chaque
semaine à la fin du trimestre on prend
les trois meilleurs des meilleurs eux
ont le droit au podium avec primes à la
clé et les cadres qui en souffrent ou
sont à peine en parler c'était importe
si vous voulez le management les
objectifs atteints ce qui compte c'est
pas tellement les personnes qui sont
fins et ses objectifs et au fur à mesure
si vous voulez bien l'être humain est
transparent disparaissait complètement
le stress n'épargne aucun secteur
d'activité au point que la justice s'en
mêle
depuis 2002 une loi impose à l'employeur
de préserver ses salariés hélas cette
obligation de protéger la santé mentale
des salariés il lorsque effectivement le
juge considère sur la base des éléments
qui lui sont fournis que l'organisation
du travail qui mise en place présente
des risques pour la santé mentale
il est parfaitement dans son droit de
suspens cette organisation
mais avant d'en arriver là l'entreprise
a une obligation faire le diagnostic des
risques psychosociaux obligation à
laquelle désormais elle ne peut se
soustraire